Let's pray together over day 39, holiness in our
lives, taking up our cross daily.
Father, we give thanks to you that you have called us to a walk
that is not a moment in time,
not a one-time event,
but a daily walk with God.
Lord, we are amazed at the beauty and the glory of
your holiness. Oh, Lord, help us. Help us to
stay connected to you, to keep your attributes, your
reality before our faces and on our lives
at all times. Lord, we pray for a regular reminder.
When we start to drift, Lord, bring us back that we might take
up our cross again and be a living sacrifice again
and expect freshness and expect new help and new
blessings from you. Oh God, we are so
quick to be distracted away from what is true and away
from what is holy.
So Lord, we need regular reminders from you.
Lord, we need fresh touch from you.
We don't want to exist on last week's truth
or the moment a year before that when you touched
us or
five or 10 years ago. We want to live in an ongoing
walking relationship with you. So Lord, we choose again
today to take up our cross and to follow you.
Holiness isn't something that just happens one time or
two times or five times, but it happens on a
daily basis as we choose to still be your people,
as we surrender our minds and our hearts and our lives and we are
drawn up into your higher kingdom.
This day, oh God, take us and let us walk
with God. We pray, oh Lord, that you would let us never be cut
off, that your life would flow from you into us.
Help us stay connected to the vine today so that
we might be holy as you are holy. We pray this in Jesus' name.
Amen.
Let's continue trusting and praying and seeking God now in your
own words.